les démineurs du service d'urgence
d'ukraine sont en forte demande autour
de kiev les batailles ont laissé des
millions d'objets explosive de toutes
sortes chaque matin les équipes
reçoivent une affectation qui répondent
aux demandes des élus des zones affligé
il faut d'abord éliminer les mines
antichars que les ukrainiens ans mais
pour freiner les blindés russes
ce sont des mines défensive légal l'
avantage c'est qu'on sait où il se
trouve
les russes ont perdu énormément de
véhicules blindés plus de 3000 dont 500
en tant qu au moins certains ont été
abandonnés ou capturés mais la plupart
détruit comme ceci
il faut s'assurer avant de s'en
approcher qu'il ne présente aucun risque
les russes tenaient une position ici
pour lancer des roquettes sur la ville
d'hier pin où se sont déroulés les
combats les plus acharnés mêler aux
débris des blindés et aux déchets
laissés par la garnison russe
possiblement des explosifs dont des
mines les démineurs avance avec prudence
les habitants voisins ont vécu des
semaines d'horreur les tanks traversait
leurs cours les soldats était agressif
et insultant mille fois ils ont eu peur
de mourir
il trouve encore deux semaines plus tard
des éclats de shrapnel autour de leur
maison la mairesse des deux villages du
coin dit que sa priorité d'empêcher que
les gens viennent dans la forêt comme
ici où l'on jacques et d'hydrater ou là
où les démineurs ne sont pas encore
passées surtout les russes ont laissé
derrière eux de ville un cadeau après
leur défaite au tour de kiev des mines
de toutes sortes et des pièges explosifs
des pièges des grenades des mines tout
ce que les russes peuvent inventer dans
leur fantaisie dit oleksandr le chef des
démineurs comme des grenades
dégoupillées dans le lave vaisselle dans
des verres sous les rampes d'escalier
dans des remises il y a eu des victimes
dans les trois dernières semaines et des
mineurs de la région de kiev ont trouvé
plus de 11000 explosif 679 hier
seulement
voici le risque que posent les mines
c'était hier dans la région de rares
kiffe le chauffeur est mort sur le coup
on a trouvé des pièges russe dans les
stations de gaz les démineurs doivent
toutes les inspecter
et puis il ya les maisons particulières
évacués au début des combats que les
russes ont habité pendant leur offensive
voici où vivaient notre collaborateur
dima il revient chez lui pour la
première fois avec les dix mineurs à
l'intérieur des objets ont été brisées
volée la maison a été laissé dans un
état lamentable
les démineurs n'ont rien trouvé il va
falloir tout nettoyer et réparer
les arbres ont été écrasés par les chars
qui stationnaient dans le jardin depuis
1999 la convention d'ottawa interdit
l'usagé des mines antipersonnel qu'on
appelle aussi larmes des lâches 131 pays
l'ont signé mais plusieurs ne l'ont pas
encore fait et pas des moindres l'inde
la chine le pakistan les états unis et
la russie des soldats en déroute se
sentent ils le droit de se venger ainsi
sur la population civile c'est un
mystère dit alexander viendront je vais
pas étonnant de plagne ne peux pas me
mettre dans la tête que quelqu'un de
raisonnable puisse faire ça y est
on peut parler de génocide dit la
mairesse ils veulent détruire l'ukraine
et le peuple ukrainien jean michel
leprince près de boudhha